nous sommes en charente ce village
chabanais a tout pour plaire
ces deux mille habitants auraient pu
vivre paisiblement dans ce cadre
bucolique
pourtant leur quotidien c'est ça
deux mille cinq cents camions traversent
tous les jours le centre ville des poids
lourds qui font la route des pays de
l'est vers l'espagne un enfer que nous
avons filmé en 2007
sylvie habite la rue principale pour
cette maman se promenait avec ses
enfants devrait être un plaisir un
moment de détente
dans la photo se dépêcher parce que
sinon ça
j'aurai ma vengeance
non non
mais quand on est le
donc ce qui fait que
on peut faire et quand on est ici pour
rentrer chez elle sylvie doit traverser
la rue avec la vitesse des camions
il faut saisir le bon moment
[Musique]
tapissier rement même les regarder on
peut faire les carreaux tous les jours
c'est même pas la peine ces temps qu'il
fasse quelque chose parce que cela je
crois que la prise de plus de gens qui
déménagent parce qu'il ne veut plus
habiter le long de la route
par ailleurs
[Musique]
dans la rue principale les maisons de ce
vide
les commerces ferment les uns après les
autres
parmi les derniers le coiffeur pour
hommes lui aussi risque de ne jamais
revendre son fonds de commerce
quand je suis arrivé il y avait seize
commerce pourquoi ils sont partis on va
chercher les gens qui puissent garé dans
la rue ça devient trop difficile alors
pour sortir on y croit ça veut dire que
les gens n'y est pas ce gars ici ils
viennent parce que ils ont confiance en
quoi cela merci allez bonne journée
ici tous les riverains craque ils
réclament une déviation qui pourrait les
débarrasser de ses poids lourds à leur
tête
françoise bretenoux pharmacienne à
chabanais avec d'autres habitants en
colère
elle a créé l'association grain de sable
la la la mon dieu si les gens
comprennent pas qu'il faut ici sortir de
son garage relève de l'exploit françoise
en sait quelque chose
[Musique]
on peut y jouer bloqué là
ah il est sympa voyez c'est ça qui est
bien c'est qu'il ya des poids lourds qui
sont quand même très sympa
ce soir avec les autres riverains
françoise a organisé une action choc une
opération escargot
ils veulent créer un embouteillage pour
alerter l'opinion sur leur calvaire ils
ont tout préparé dans le plus grand
secret car il ne voulait pas que les
gendarmes soient au courant sinon les
forces de l'ordre aurait dévié le trafic
[Musique]
restant les gendarmes ne sont pas là et
cependant ils vont être au courant très
très vite parce que il ya des gens qui
vont les appeler c'est sûr
au bout de quelques minutes seulement
une centaine de camions se retrouvent
piégés dans un bouchon de 3 km de long
et soudain quelques képi apparaissent en
haut de la côte
oui jacques c'est françoise je pense que
le comité d'accueil nous attendons la
hausse après la ligne droite trop
longtemps les gendarmes
donc la consigne était de rester sur la
route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françoise habituellement paisible
pharmacienne n'est pas habitué à défier
les forces de l'ordre cela la rend
plutôt mal à l'aise mais bon c'est
toujours difficile quand on n'a jamais
fait ça
[Musique]
de se lancer dans de décider de faire
des manifs je trouve que c'est difficile
c'est pour moi c'est pas quelque chose
d'évident
c'est contraire un peu à ma nature je
veux dire mais c'est la seule façon de
se faire entendre
donc je pense à ces terres est quand
même d'être en france et d'être obligé
de passer par un peu une sorte de
violence même si elle est gentille pour
dire vous voyez regardez ce qu'ils
pensent on vous l'a dit mais vous me
fait rien alors qu'elle est offert dans
le convoi il y à michel jas la jasse le
maire de chabanais qui lui aussi brave
l'autorité malgré son statut d'élu
[Musique]
tiens y'avait je crois que la
gendarmerie arriva
on ne sait jamais agréable de se prouver
dans l'inégalité mais d'un autre côté je
préfère finalement me trouvais un peu
dans l'illégalité
mais ici de vous faire entendre
que l'on puisse trouver le plus
rapidement possible une solution à ce
problème qui nous va a qu'un empire ans
et qui ne peut et qui peut engendrer des
conséquences traumatiques cette
opération escargot c'est un peu le
combat du pot de terre contre le pot de
fer
car c'est au plus haut niveau que se
décident les projet de déviation et les
habitants espèrent maintenant un geste
de l'état
[Musique]
je crois c'est une réussite alors montés
sont pas les bras c'est vrai que la
partie est loin d'être gagnée
et c'est tout alors merci
[Musique]
bonjour deux mois plus tard jérôme
lambert le député de la circonscription
de chabanais se rend à paris au
ministère des transports
ce jour là le ministre en personne
dominique bussereau va présider une
réunion décisive dont l'enjeu la
déviation
on a regardé des délais de rouler plus
vite aussi prêter tous il faut qu'on ait
le foncier et à long termes en 2009 dont
la fin d'année 2009 pourquoi recommencer
contre les départs en 2009 et ben et
rend service à l'humiliation à 100 pour
tous les financements nécessaires
habib 2012 mais attention il ne s'agit
pour l'instant que d'une promesse
[Musique]
un an plus tard en ce début 2009
nous sommes retournés à chabanais
[Musique]
dans le centre ville les riverains
attendent avec impatience la réalisation
de la déviation
car au quotidien c'est toujours l'enfer
même le simple fait de décharger son
bois devient périlleux
[Musique]
h
j'ai toujours peur qu'il y ait un pépin
bien sûr j'ai pas le choix recommencer
beaucoup jordy avait une chanson qui
vous est dur dur d'être bébé mais moi je
dis dur dur d'être mémé dans la rue
souchet 1 écoutez le trafic est toujours
à peu près le même
il n'y a qu'une chose soit disant les
tracés sont faits on attend et
maintenant ce que j'attends de voir moi
c'est la bulle de verre 1 quand j'aurai
du petit louis-joseph dirai ça y est
c'est parti
voilà le coiffeur pour hommes est
toujours présent mais au bout de
quarante années de carrière il va
raccrocher ses ciseaux sans revendre son
fonds de commerce
je vais prendre ma retraite
j'aurai un manque à gagner parce que je
bonbons à faire tomber quoi sera quand
je vais baisser le rideau c'est fini je
pense
[Musique]
mais ça fait bizarre parce que moi j'ai
pris je suis rentré ici un apprentissage
et de laisser tomber comme ça ça ça me
fait un peu de ça me fait un peu de
peine quoi parce que j'aime bien mon
métier
et puis voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les deux seules nouveautés à chabanais
on les trouve à l'hôtel de ville
d'abord le maire michel jas la jasse
s'est laissé pousser la moustache mais
surtout le plan de la déviation est
enfin terminé la déviation se profile le
projet est de réaliser donc autour de
chabanais une deux fois deux voies qui
va contourner chabanais par l'est et le
sud
ça c'est une première tranche de travaux
qui doit être réalisée avant fin 2012
puisque on nous a promis la livraison
des ouvrages à fin 2012 mais pour voir
la déviation sortir de terre il reste
une dernière étape
elle doit absolument être inscrits dans
ce qu'on appelle le est mis c'est le
programme des travaux routiers de france
pour les cinq ans à venir
françoise la pharmacienne attend cette
inscription avec impatience mais
aujourd'hui un article de la charente
libre l'a fait sursauter aujourd'hui
monsieur fillon et donc à lyon pour
annoncer un plan de relance qui va
consister aide pour l'aménagement de
autoroutier voilà alors ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que il ya un seul
projet qui apparaît en poitou charentes
il conserve la rn11 et nous et nous et
nous on est où
donc c'est ça qui est affolant
immédiatement françois écrit à tous les
élus de la région avec une autre
habitante de chabanais elle consulte les
réponses
voilà elle nous dit j'ai lu comme vous
la charente il ce matin le plan de
relance n'a rien à voir vous intéresse
avec la rn 141
donc ce qu'on a vu dans la charente clic
c'est le plan de relance mais le mais
c'est pour fin février un problème c'est
que c'est tellement compliqué on arrive
à tout mélanger
quelle journée plage et et après une
journée d'angoissé
aujourd'hui françoise à paniquer pour
rien finalement un mois plus tard la
déviation de chabanais sera bien
inscrite au pdmi les derniers
financements vont être débloqués
chabanais devrait retrouver son calme
dans quatre ans fin 2012 ailleurs en
france
d'autres citoyens sont entrés en
résistance
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur de la bretagne bien
loin de la mer dans la ville de carhaix
plouguer où vivent 8000 habitants dans
très peu de temps
ils seront 1 de plus elle est pas sorti
sans moi même attendu à la fois des la
bbc voilà voilà ça c'est une belle
poussée aller continu continu continu
continu continu allait longtemps
longtemps longtemps longtemps longtemps
voilà superbe
bienvenue au monde bienvenue à carhaix
ouais
[Musique]
anaïs qui est fière d'un quart et je
suis sûr l'onyx oui tout à fait
tranquille novices aux 50 pour bébés
chaque année comme anaïs 250 bébés
naissent chaque arrêt mais aujourd'hui
cette maternité et le service de
chirurgie de l'hôpital sont menacés de
fermeture
à 42 ans monsieur le maire de carhaix
entame son deuxième mandat
christian troadec vient d'être réélu
triomphalement avec 68% des voix
farouche défenseur de l'hôpital ce matin
là il a les yeux rivés sur le registre
des naissances
l'enac revient à peu près nulle sur le
début d'année 84 quand même des on sait
bien on est en augmentation par rapport
à l'an passé
ça montre l'utilité de la maternité sur
carhaix en tout cas donc il nous faut
connaître les chiffres pour pouvoir
aussi rétorqué à ceux qui veulent nous
la ferme et que c'est un outil
indispensable à la santé en centre
bretagne le centre hospitalier de
carhaix n'est pas le seul à être menacée
par la nouvelle politique de santé au
total dans toute la france 250 hôpitaux
de proximité sont susceptibles de
disparaître ou de perdre des services
pour des raisons budgétaires mais pour
monsieur le maire
l'hôpital de carhaix a une particularité
son isolement géographique
evans et ce calibre manqué très serré ya
du vent on voit l'hôpital
[Musique]
si les services de maternité et de
chirurgie qui sont vraiment menacé
aujourd'hui a été appelée à fermer et
bien les gens seraient contraints
d'aller à plus d'une heure de route
on est vraiment dans une exception
géographique ici on est on est à peu
isolés en fin de compte puisqu'on est en
plein coeur de la bretagne est donc
l'hôpital le plus proche c'est sur
morlaix mais on est à on est aussi à 50
55 minutes de route de cet hôpital faut
passer par cette route pour arriver
jusqu à morlaix et souvent en hiver ces
essais ont déjà il ya du verglas à une
femme enceinte elle a mille fois le
temps d'accoucher dans l'ambulance avant
d'arriver jusqu'à morlaix car est au
carrefour de trois départements
l'hôpital de morlaix donc à 50 minutes
en voiture à condition de ne croiser ni
tracteur ni intempéries
quimper et à une heure brest encore plus
loin
si la chirurgie et la maternité
disparaissent à carhaix comment seront
soignés les 80000 habitants du centre
ouest bretagne
il n'y a pas de clinique dans le secteur
très peu de médecins spécialistes et la
moitié des généralistes à plus de 55 ans
cette région est elle condamnée à
devenir un désert sanitaire
[Musique]
personne n'avait les champs tu veux pas
de céréales à la marie laure guillot à
35 ans elle est infirmière au service de
chirurgie lui aussi menacé de fermeture
toi tu te rappelles pas kaminis rappelle
peut-être
ses grandes soeurs l'a vait un an et
demi après avoir travaillé à paris puis
en afrique pour des missions
humanitaires
il y a dix ans marie laure a choisi de
revenir à carhaix je suis attachée à
l'hôpital
premièrement parce que des jeux je suis
né à carhaix g j'ai grandi ici et puis
je connais la population donc je suis
soignante à l'hôpital
et donc je sais vraiment que les
versions swan ont besoin de ces trucs
tél face aux rumeurs de fermeture un
comité de défense de l'hôpital a été
créé marie-laure en est le porte parole
toutes les sensibilités ils sont
représentés ce matin marie laure a tout
juste le temps de déposer ses enfants à
l'école car dans moins de trois heures
elle doit être à rennes où va se décider
l'avenir de l'hôpital
je suis pas politique je sais pas du
tout militante je me suis retrouvée par
carole un peu au hasard
ils ont demandé est ce qu'il y avait des
volontaires les doit s'élever pas
beaucoup je me suis dit allez je vais
tenter de sauver l'événement doit on
verra bien c'est donc sa toute première
mobilisation à la 4 car on transportait
280 jusqu'à rennes parmi eux de nombreux
usagers de l'hôpital comme régine soigné
pour une spondylarthrite qui découvre le
mégaphone à manifester qu'une seule fois
dans sa vie c'était en 1984 pour
défendre l'école privée
[Musique]
rivas la lèche
dans chaque région la rh l' agence
régionale d'hospitalisation est chargée
par le ministère de la santé d'organiser
les soit le sort de la maternité et de
la chirurgie est donc entre les mains de
son directeur antoine perrin
[Musique]
dans cette dynamique en carton
marie-laure transporte une pétition
signée par 28 1080 une personne fort du
soutien de la population
le maire christian troadec est prêt à
défendre bec et ongles l'hôpital de sa
ville
le directeur antoine perrin accueille la
délégation royale c'est radec non s'il
vous plaît elle monsieur le maire vous
monsieur le maire mais pas chez le 26
août à larache puisqu'il s'agit ici d'un
lieu public monsieur troadec
tu pouvais j'ai fait ici d'un lieu
public ouvert à tout le monde ça dès
qu'on est à l'air si nous sommes ici des
élus du boeuf
nous demandons à pouvoir assister à
cette possibilité de discussion entre
nous donc je demanderai aux élus de
pouvoir entrer ainsi que la délégation
alors les élus la délégation sans
problème mais c'est très cette réunion
il a précédemment
non après cela on croit pas messieurs
mesdames souvient rentrée non non non
monsieur trop avec le ton est donné
le soutien sonore des carhaisiens n'y
fera rien l'ambiance va retomber comme
un soufflé car au bout de quelques
minutes
marie-laure ressort brièvement le visage
fermé et c'est du n'importe quoi c'est
de la fermeture pure et simple de la
maternité et la chirurgie et et voilà
c'est honteux c'est vraiment honteux
pour retrouver un équilibre financier
l'hôpital de carhaix doit donc être
amputé de sa maternité et de sa
chirurgie pas assez rentable un
traitement de choc que le maire refuse
sur le champ
[Applaudissements]
une sortie ratée le soir des baïonnettes
et
hasard du calendrier c'est aussi en tant
que père que le maire est concerné par
cette affaire
sa compagne nadine attendent leur
troisième enfant
c'est tellement important pour nous que
cet hôpital qui font qu'il faut que ça
tienne un faux pas qui nous l'enlève
sinon c'est la cata toutes les femmes
qui doivent accoucher d'une machine et
trois quarts d'heure avant de pouvoir
accéder à une maternité
c'est pas ce qu'il peut se passer je
trouve ça aberrant je n'y serai pas à
passer la nuit 1
le siège s'organise du cinquième étage
surgissent des rallonges électriques
nous et les unes aux autres
ce qui va permettre le ravitaillement
des troupes les fraises tagada sont en
train de monter avec de l'eau et le
sandwich on va voir
les heures passent la nuit tombe
mais l'ambiance jusque-là bonne enfant
va changer après une dizaine d'heures
d'occupation et carhaisien sont expulsés
manu militari par les policiers
[Applaudissements]
mais
aucun moment les gendarmes nous ont dit
sortez où ils ont pas frapper à la porte
ils ont défoncé la porte on était
derrière on a volé le dialogue voilà le
dialogue
le gars a dit dès lors imaginer pour les
autres hôpitaux comment ça va se passer
c'est un gouvernement qui a décidé de
faire des économies sur le dos de la
santé publique et ça c'est pas
acceptable
et c'est pas en envoyant les forces de
l'ordre que ces gens là vont gagner
et
la fermeture n'est donc plus une rumeur
même si aucune date n'est fixée
il est 3 heures du matin pour l'hôpital
de carhaix la bataille ne fait que
commencer
[Musique]
réputé pour être un meneur d'hommes
dès le lendemain christian troadec prend
tout naturellement la tête de la
rébellion et la population le sud au
coeur de l'armorique d'irréductibles
bretons ont donc décidé de résister
c'est un peuple ici qui sait dire non
ken capacités d'animation qui est très
forte et qui lorsqu'elle voit qu'il ya
des injustices qui sont commises et d'un
réagi immédiatement je crois que ça doit
dans le sens des gens ici d'ailleurs ici
les paysans se sont révoltés contre le
pouvoir royal et les seigneurs locaux
100 ans avant la révolution française
et là c'est l'hôpital et je crois que
c'est encore plus qu'une autre cause je
crois ce qui rassemble les gens parce
que là c'est toutes les générations
c'est toutes les couches sociales c'est
toute la population qui se retrouve
derrière son hôpital l'hôpital de
carhaix a vu le jour en 1934 il a été
entièrement rénové il y à peine 10 ans
600 personnes sont employées dans cet
établissement 1700 malades ils sont
opérés chaque année au service de
chirurgie marie-laure un repris son
travail à la place d'accueillir depuis
le retour de rennes l'angoissent de la
fermeture est dans tous les esprits
celui des soignants celui des malades
cette patiente vient de se faire poser
une deuxième prothèse de hanche et tous
les gens de l'ombre a les moyens d'aller
à brest quimper vous dire ce qu'il en
est ç'aurait été compliqué pour vous
d'organiser même une intervention
programmée à brest ce qu'est les
rendez-vous faut retourner vers un
anesthésient sofa enfin il faut
retourner pour faire les trucs de cardio
grain on est ici pour moi tout fait le
même jour que j'ai pas eu besoin d'aller
courir la droite et à gauche
voilà ça tout s'est très bien passé je
suis content de parler je reviendrai
encore d'autres fois c'est dommage ou
d'une autre jambe
à tout à l'heure à tourner merci aller à
brest c'est une expédition pour les
personnes d'ici et je pense qu'à
pourrait pourrait renoncer aux soins
plutôt que d'avoir justement ce très
cher
dans cette région on meurt déjà plus
jeune que dans le reste de la bretagne
car les habitants tarder à consulter et
les maladies sont souvent découverte à
un stade avancé
à l'heure de sa pause déjeuner
marie-laure quitte sa blouse blanche
mais pas l'hôpital devant l'entrée deux
tentes ont été plantées baptisé le
camping de la résistance patients et
soignants ci informe font des dons et
signent des pétitions avaient déjà signé
la pétition
la maternité j'ai pas le permis on a dû
appeler les pompiers pour lui si donc
non pour la peine dix minutes sinon ça à
morlaix c'est une heure et demie elle a
accouché donc alors la queue chez dans
le quatre pompiers qui est grande serre
mais la maternité très bien sûr parce
que nous ne la région parisienne où un
car à la base et non non c'est un peu
plus les initie on est proche je trouve
les avec sa chanson si tu mets une deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec moins d'une naissance par jour les
douches chambre de la maternité sont
rarement toutes occupées mais les sept
sages femmes ont le temps d'accompagner
véritablement les familles
[Musique]
on se refait ici les papas peuvent
dormir aux côtés de leur nouveau né
à défaut de la quantité la maternité de
carhaix mise sur la qualité
nadine la compagne du maire doit
accoucher dans trois mois
elle a rendez-vous à la maternité car
pour l'instant rien n'a changé le suivi
des femmes enceintes se poursuit je
m'inscrire sur les découverts comme la
soie rouge bon ok est ce que vous avez
fait des cours les autres il ya huit ans
et demi oui j'avoue et pour le deuxième
j'avais pas fait parce que ses
représentants siègent à et gpu besoin
parce que j'ai une scène
donc j'ai envie bien préparée bien zen
préparer des cours d'après en un peu
après au riz pour toi tu mer se sera pas
fermée non si jamais si jamais sa ferme
et non non core hors de question qu est
optimiste on sera dans quinze jours
quinze jours trois semaines dans votre
ouais ok to ventre dehors avec 12 autres
femmes enceintes
nadine a créé un collectif peu encline à
accoucher en hélicoptère ou dans un
camion de pompiers elles veulent
apporter leur pierre à la défense de la
maternité
bah on va aller faire un petit coucou
préparation à l'accouchement à la maison
des services publics ce qui est le
bureau ses symboles et car c'est juste
parce qu'elle bureau du ce prix qu'elles
accouchent dans deux jours un mois ou
trois elles sont les premières
concernées les premières angoisses et
nul ne sait où naîtra son bébé vous
saurez vous saurez quand partir ayez
confiance en vous il faut avoir
confiance en nous plus rien d'agréable
quand on gâche le moment complètement
d'une manière ou d'une autre qu'on reste
tous qu'on parte quoi on accouchera
c'est sûr mais
j'ai enfin pas du tout dans le var ce
qu'on voulait faire dans le contexte
qu'on voulait quoi et ça y est pour
assurer sa votre foi de grossesse vous
allez très mal la vie mais c'est bien
mais ce serait bien de match
[Musique]
depuis sa mairie christian troadec
cherche toujours à se faire entendre de
l'état pour se rappeler au bon souvenir
du préfet de quimper aujourd'hui tous
les coups de fil adressé à la mairie de
carhaix sont renvoyés automatiquement au
standard de la préfecture et des
dizaines de maires du centre ouest
bretagne font de même oui bonjour adams
et christian troadec le maire de carhaix
l'appareil
je vous appelle vous vérifiez si nos
dispositifs pour gêner le préfet du
finistère a fonctionné à merveille
vous avez beaucoup de coups de chien
bah on voulait présenter nos excuses aux
standardistes pas du tout contre les
standardistes eu à ce point là non mais
surtout que c'est une opération qui va
se poursuivre en plus donc je pense que
ça va se renouveler régulièrement
merci madame bonne soirée ça occupe
combien de votre temps le combat pour le
maintien de la maternité de la chirurgie
aujourd'hui beaucoup de temps j'allais
dire même énormément je pense qu'on y
consacre aussi une partie de la nuit
parce que on cesse d'y réfléchir surtout
la cram c'est de se tromper de stratégie
parce qu'on cède au combat va être très
dur très rude on a en face de nous un
rouleau compresseur
mais c'est un combat quand on sait que
c'est sans doute un des combats les plus
importants que le pays elle veut mener
ses trente ou quarante dernières années
christian troadec et fils et petit-fils
d'agriculteurs depuis 20 ans il
s'implique et s'applique à faire vivre
sa région avec une bande de copains il a
d'abord créé les vieilles charrues qui
est devenu un des plus grand festival
européen de musiques plus de 200000
spectateurs à carhaix l'été dernier on
va faire les zones industrielles a qui
sont qui sont très très développée sur
carhaix on va en ouvrir plusieurs encore
dans les mois à venir si des entreprises
et des lotissements sortent de terre si
carey a gagné en attractivité
c'est le fruit d'années d'efforts que le
maire ne voudrait pas voir ruiné par la
fermeture de la maternité et de la
chirurgie voici un pays ici qui a eu à
lutter pour maintenir ces emplois et qui
est parvenu parce que c'est pas très
sympa on est ici dans une région
essentiellement agricole et
agroalimentaire et il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui s'installe sur sur la
région et on a en même temps en plus une
population alors qu'elle diminuait dans
les vingt dernières années qui se
stabilise stabiliser désormais on
recommence à gagner des habitants
donc c'est vrai alors qu au moment où on
attendait plutôt de la part de l'état de
nous aider dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du territoire ils viennent
nous mettre vraiment un coup de à coup
de massue sur la tête
[Musique]
marie laure a passé la vitesse
supérieure dorénavant le comité de
défense de l'hôpital enchaîne les
réunions usagers et soignants y
expriment leur inquiétude qui elle
aborder stratégie le maire marie laure
les médecins les carhaisiens
parviendront-ils à empêcher la fermeture
de leur maternité de leur chirurgie dont
il même en avoir le temps des roches pas
si je me mets chose la seule certitude
c'est qu'à carhaix on opère on accouche
et désormais on résiste jours et non
après il faut qu'à une présence 24
heures sur une catho niveau de ce
camping on en a décidé le 30 avril
contiendrait gains pour montrer notre
détermination à lutter jour ce temps
qu'il faut pas fermer d'un globe la nuit
et des services de nez vous savez qu'on
est en bretagne c'est un peu moi je vais
en découle un jour j'aurai campé sur
parking de l'hôpital demain
[Musique]
il ya six heures et demie pour sarko si
tu savais tout le mal que tu fais
[Rires]
un après midi de printemps au coeur des
landes
c'est ici que vit françois dans cette
ferme du 19e siècle qu'il retape depuis
plus de 15 ans
pour lui sa femme et leurs trois enfants
ce fut un coup de coeur mais aujourd'hui
françois vient de recevoir un document
inquiétant le tracé définitif d'une
autoroute qui va passer dans ce champ
juste à côté de chez lui dans le trophée
est un peu loin mais ça passe avec un
angle si ainsi fermé que ça me passe au
ras de la maison quoi pour être fixé
françois va mesurer la distance qui
sépare la maison du tracé de l'autoroute
il réalise alors l'ampleur des dégâts
pour lui et sa famille
résultat voilà l'autoroute passe à 50
mètres de la maison sans tenir compte
que ce soit un cadre de vie que ce soit
une fille que ce soit un investissement
que soit là où vous ayez élever vos
enfants que vous vouliez lutran leur
transmettre quelque chose sur lequel sur
quoi vous avez travaillé pendant 15 ans
si le calendrier des travaux est
respecté
l'autoroute a65 sera ouverte à la
circulation fin 2010 150 kilomètres de
bitume entre pau et langon coût de la
construction un milliard deux cent mille
euros avec la 65
bordeaux ne sera plus qu'à deux heures
de pur contre trois actuellement
mais la 65 première autoroute de l'après
grenelle de l'environnement ne fait pas
l'unanimité en aquitaine
les opposants dénoncent un projet qui
passe en plein coeur des landes la plus
grande forêt d'europe
aliénor la société concessionnaire
filières du groupe eiffage promet en
revanche de construire une autoroute
verte respectueuse de la nature et de
ses habitants
[Musique]
aujourd'hui françois reçoit les
négociateurs envoyé par a'liénor ils
sont chargés de l'acquisition des
terrains nécessaires au passage de
l'autoroute
attention nous n'avons pas été autorisés
à filmer la rencontre la discussion
démarre sur les futurs nuisances sonores
françois espère qu'un aménagement lui
sera proposé documents à l'appui
le négociateur lui apprend que le bruit
ne dépassera pas 55 décibels et que rien
n'est prévu dans ce cas vu le jour et la
nuit
je peux vous dire par corot mise en
pratique
aujourd'hui ils font les aménagements en
ce sens du résultat de ces étuis donc vu
que pour eux on reste dans les normes
imposées par la loi
il estime que la paix d'aménagement pas
d'aménagement cela signifie que françois
n'aura pas de murs antibruit
la loi n'impose cette construction qu'à
partir de 60 décibels à 5 décibels près
pas de chance vous êtes arrêté sur des
airs de station d'autoroute
parce que la chute il vraiment vous
entendez le barouf que ça fait c'est
monstrueux françois est scandalisé mais
reste patient il veut connaître le
montant proposé pour l'achat d'un bout
de son terrain soit 175 m² mais quand le
négociateur sort sa calculette
il croit à une plaisanterie 168 euros
pour 175 m² avec un petit bonus si
l'accord se conclu à l'amiable faits
attendez 1200 euros par hectare n'engage
donc b ça fait mouche et donc vont nous
proposer au total 789 euros c'est pas
mal je vous sais bien donc aliénant vous
a dit me proposait 189 euros et amiable
donc si je veux pas je n'aurai que son
68 euros je prends intérêt à vouloir non
pour l'interner euro veulent pas me
faire un petit bisou en plus 189 euros
c'est tout ce que propose aliénor le
constructeur
alors qu'avec le passage de l'autoroute
la maison de françois va perdre 40% de
sa valeur aujourd'hui de reconnaître le
préjudice
dire aujourd'hui concision mon billet
avec une autoroute à côté il viendra 40%
pas n'importe oui mais aujourd'hui mais
ça c'est parce que le tour n'est pas
mise en service donc on peut pas les
civils
la dépréciation non seulement françois
va devoir attendre la mise en service de
l'autoroute avant de contester mais en
plus c'est à l'état qu'il va devoir
demander des comptes et les services de
l'état indemnise toujours au minimum
à 70 km plus au sud à domi dans les
pyrénées atlantiques les travaux de l'a
65 sont déjà bien avancé sur le tracé de
l'autoroute
des centaines de tonnes de terre ont été
retournés sous les yeux de valérie
agricultrice et de didier son mari
depuis la fin de l'été il contemple le
ballet des machines toutes ces terres
leur appartenait il y élevait des
poulets et exploitaient la ferme
familiale
[Musique]
en terre c'était du bois mais voilà ils
ont été traversées de bichat tous les
matins on voyait traverser les buses
dans le champ etc
ça fait cliché mais c'est quand même ça
la vérité les travaux ont coupé
l'exploitation en deux d'un côté la
ferme de l'autre les champs et le bois
qui n'ont pas été vendus à l'autoroute
didier reste vigilant à tout moment le
chantier potent piété sur les terres qui
lui reste
bon ça c'est mon plein moi c'est le plan
de situation de la maison ont fait
bondir de la propriété et moi comme ça
moi je sais exactement on sait que je
suis dans quelle parcelle je suis donc
je sais à peu près ce que je peux me
baser quoi voir si je sais moi qui suis
en tort ou bien où est fâché car la
cohabitation avec les travaux est très
mauvaise et les incidents nombreux comme
ce matin voyez les gens qui sont dans le
bois la bafin bas ils ont pas y être
donc ils se demandent pourquoi ils y
sont et qu'est ce qu'ils font donc il va
s'accrocher encore certainement avec
il supporte plus les façons de faire oui
mais on dit on nous traite de gaulois
ont et ceux qui résistent et ses copains
à l'appel à ramon x parce
qu'effectivement il est tout le temps en
train de résister à ce gros rouleau
compresseur quoi mais c'est quand même
pas sans mal et voilà on est il est pas
bien quoi
donc là il doit avoir le palpitant qui
s'énerve un peu didier soupçonne les
géomètres de vouloir annexer un bout de
terrain dans le bois qui lui appartient
pour en avoir le coeur net il se rend
sur place et découvrent que de nouveau
piqué ont été plantés chez lui
visiblement le chantier est en train de
s'étendre
ils sont en cours chez moi et là
normalement c'est un prix ce n'est pas
prévu par rapport à l'autoroute est
compliqué de plus donc qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire
là ils vont être obligés de casser tout
le bois qui a pris va vouloir donner
mais dans quel état
une nouvelle fois didier valérie sont
obligés de demander des explications
une situation qu'ils vivent quasiment
tous les jours
cependant le banc ils vont aller boire
ou dont vous avez quatre et non
domaniaux là si je vois pas les
géomètres une fois de plus prendre et
dans le bois il ya personne qui me dit
rien encore une fois de plus l'homme
n'est que le chef d'equipe il ne sait
rien et décide d'appeler son supérieur
regardez piquée qui trompe et un blog il
paraît que le propriétaire didier et
valérie ont bien fait d'insister
ils vont bientôt rencontrer un
responsable mais ils ne vont pas être
déçus
les personnes qui vient y viennent par
leur dirai qu'ils ont une bonne
mentalité
par contre vous leur dites si l'on peut
de couilles qui viennent me voir un
petit peu gentiment non oui mais bon si
je travaille vous pouvez leur dire à vos
chefs là ils sont même pas daigné se
retourner et failli s'en passer en
existe peu et maintenant on saura pas
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est pourquoi
ils ont mis 16 qui vont nous prendre un
peu plus de maïs est ce qu'ils vont de
nouveau les cases et comme l'a si c'est
pas c'est pas normal c'est pas normal
alors qu'il nous dise pas que ça se
passe bien retour dans les landes encore
préservée du chantier de l'autoroute
tout est très calme seuls quelques
panneaux d'aliénor annonce l'arrivée
prochaine des travaux nous retrouvons
françois accompagné yvonne sa voisine de
village ils ont décidé de faire une
tournée de leur quartier
bientôt traversé par l'autoroute
françois even sont tous les deux membres
d'une association qui milite contre la
cette maison va avoir le grillage à 6050
dans cette trouée passera juste
l'autoroute et il ya l'autre maison
d'habitation aussitôt alors là il ya un
bon dieu l'autoroute tout c'est là tout
ça c'est sa cage et aujourd'hui ils ont
pris rendez vous avec jean claude un
vieil ami dit veulent mais moi oui
aujourd'hui bonjour ancien facteur
jean-claude voulait passer sa retraite
dans sa maison de famille et mes enfants
sont nés ici
et alors ça fait quand même mal au coeur
alors tout ça ça va sauter le cingle que
l'on avait plein d'idées qu'on avait
planté le tout petit depuis qu'il a
appris que l'autoroute traversait son
jardin jean claude est sous
anti-dépresseurs s'est pas encore fait
c'est peut-être à toi d'essayer de
réagir tout y est né ici qu'a prévu d'y
passer la retraite ça y est tu y es
voilà c'est dommage c'est le mange le
jour ça voir disparaître
je ne sais pas
parce que c'est pour toute la vie après
ses pas il m'a fait de la peine
[Musique]
françois et yvonne se bat depuis 13 ans
contre le projet pour démontrer que
l'autoroute est inutile il ne compte
plus les heures passées sur le dossier
de l'autoroute
ils ont frappé aux portes de toutes les
administrations pour collecter les
informations officielles sur le trafic
régional
le nombre d'accidents les conclusions du
grenelle le coup de l'autoroute
le nombre de propriétés touchées par le
tracé un dossier c'est ça et tous les
post it
ils sont sur toutes les pages ce sont
des analyses tous les écrits surligner
un travail de fourmi
c'est dur d'entendre par exemple des
politiques qui devant de cet autre de
dire qu'on ment quand nous sur les
trafics par exemple on relève tout ça
alors les menteurs c'est alors la
direction départementale de l'équipement
le conseil général des landes
nous ne reprenons que ces chiffres là
nous n'inventons jamais un chiffre on
n'a rien sur quoi on peut nous attaquer
alors on nous ridiculisent parce qu'on
essaie de sauver le vison d'europe le
l'écrevisse à pattes blanches la cistude
la loutre on se moque de nous on essaie
de nous tourner en dérision tout est
fait pour nous bâillonner
tout est fait pour que la vérité ne soit
pas su ou que nos arguments soient
passées pour des
des faits émanant d'une secte à la
limite nous sommes des rétrogrades
qui sont là pour batailler parce qu'il
faut batailler depuis des années
françois et tous les opposants proposent
une autre solution
élargir la route existante il y voit
deux avantages sécurisé et enfin cette
départementale réputée dangereuse et
limiter le coût des travaux
stéphane lui aussi est un opposant à la
65 et ils empruntent régulièrement la
départementale pour lui l'autoroute est
tout simplement une aberration
économique le trafic est trop faible
elle ne sera jamais rentable je
l'emprunté c'est souvent pour me rendre
à bordeaux
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de souci j'ai jamais été en
retard côté embouteillages ou quoi que
ce soit
jamais
il ya 6000 véhicules par jour
c'est très peu
on veut en faire une autre à côté
au nom du progrès et du développement
l'autoroute va aussi détruire un site
naturel unique l'étang des neuf
fontaines en plein coeur de la forêt des
landes un lieu cher à stéphane le lieu
de son enfance
alors tu fais attention tu parle
doucement si tu vas voir c'est la reine
de pêche je te mantra exactement où
bah ouais ce patrimoine stéphane aurait
voulu le transmettre à julien son fils
de 12 ans j'allais boire à la source
cela m'étonnerait grand père il venait à
boire ici il n'y avait pas l'eau et dans
les maisons
il venait à chercher ici les temps des
neuf fontaines un paradis pour la
biodiversité bientôt traversé par un
viaduc autoroutier
s'il a juste à quelques mètres on va
avoir un viaduc de 75 mètres de long qui
va passer au dessus de ce site donc bien
sûr les retombées nous disent que ils
vont passer sans polluer je ne vois pas
comment commander camions vont passer au
dessus de ces sources sans aucune
retombée dans la source c'est pas
possible c'est un gros mensonge c'est
avec très dur ça va être très dur de
voir ça
c'est une catastrophe
pour stéphane impossible de savoir quand
les travaux commenceront mais
l'association des opposants promet de
tout faire pour empêcher la destruction
de ce site exceptionnel
[Musique]
nous sommes en auvergne dans le sud du
cantal dans cette vallée pas d'autoroute
ni du sinn juste un village de 200
habitants breuzon ici les magasins ont
fermé les uns après les autres
sauf le bar restaurant heureusement il
reste un endroit encore plein de vie
c'est l'école
[Musique]
nous sommes en juin 2007 cette année là
c'est l'inquiétude à breuzon car
l'administration a décidé de fermer
cette classe unique
alors on ce matin les cycles 3
c'est-à-dire ce2 cm1 cm2 ont travaillé
en géographie à midi les écoliers
prennent le chemin de la cantine
[Musique]
une cantine pas comme les autres
depuis 20 ans le bar de laval et reçoit
les enfants c'est le dernier lieu de
convivialité du village mais tout ça
pourrait bien disparaître
[Musique]
car début 2007 un courrier officiel est
arrivé à la mairie
jeanine cayrol la secrétaire a ressorti
la lettre mais voilà nous avons reçu un
arrêté de respecter academy daté du 15
février 2007 qui nous dit fermeture de
classe unique à compter du 1er septembre
2007 avec jeanine jambes hugo lemaire de
breuzon cet agriculteur a décidé
d'entrer en résistance
il va assigner l'inspection académique
devant le tribunal administratif faut
tout le temps se battre il faut tout le
temps se battre pour défendre quelque
chose dans les petites communes beuvray
tout est en train de disparaître
malgré qu'on en fasse de la pression il
ya des fois que on est dépassé
malgré que on se bat on est dépassé
parce que c'est les administrations
centrales qui décide qui prennent la
place des élus pourquoi mes décisions
monsieur le maire s'est déjà battu une
première fois il ya dix ans pour éviter
la fermeture de l'école jean buron et
son premier adjoint ont investi l'argent
de la commune dans ce bâtiment pour
accueillir douze petits parisiens sous
la protection des services sociaux une
partie de ces enfants vient augmenter
les effectifs de l'école
mais aujourd'hui la classe unique n'a
toujours qu'une petite dizaine d'élèves
pas assez selon l'inspection académique
la faire disparaître ce serait
inacceptable pour jeanine car elle a été
l'institutrice du village pendant quinze
ans dans cette classe elle retrouve ses
souvenirs
on va ouvrir
il ya des photos au cas là voilà une ici
donc il y avait quand même pas mal
d'élèves
avant jeanine de nombreux instituteurs
se sont succédé pendant plus d'un siècle
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque les effectifs était
pléthorique bronze on comptait une
cinquantaine d'écoliers
on est loin de la classe unique
d'aujourd'hui
si l'école ferme les nouvelles familles
hésiteront à s'installer à breuzon le
village risque de s'éteindre peu à peu
on parle que de chiffres et d'argent on
ne parle plus d'humanité on ne parle
plus des valeurs on ne parle plus de ce
qui est important on ne parle plus que
d'argent et de rentabilité
bon alors est ce que l'école doit être
rentable est-ce que l'éducation doit
être rentable est-ce que l'avenir des
enfants c'est la rentabilité
la question vaut là pour dénoncer cette
politique
jeanine s'engage dans un projet fou
organisé une manifestation à bruson
village qui ne fait habituellement
jamais parler de lui
et le jour j c'est un succès
[Musique]
de mémoire de bronze au nez on n'avait
jamais vu ça plus de 100 personnes
défilent dans les rues
[Musique]
et
les colonnes
les enfants
oh
le maire d'un petit village voisin prend
le micro
j'ai vu moi même disparaître mon école
quasiment le jour où j'étais élu il y a
plein de quatre ans j'ai vu ensuite bien
évidemment disparaître le petit commerce
qui existaient la petite épicerie et
ainsi de suite voir disparaître une
école c'est un peu la mort qui pénètre
dans une commune mais jeanine ne
s'arrête pas là pour sauver l'école il
faut multiplier les inscriptions
d'élèves
alors elle a une autre idée audacieuse
repeupler breuzon on aimerait pouvoir
faire venir une famille avec des enfants
donc on voudrait passer une annonce
passée une simple annonce sur un
magazine pour trouver une famille ça
semble irréel qu'est ce que tu en penses
jean noël ont fait des demandes pour
qu'il y ait des artisans qui s'installe
c'est possible oui parole m on va leur
apporter avant verbier est étonnamment
ça marche en temps non
oui bonjour
deux semaines plus tard jeanine a rendez
vous avec une grenobloise
cette jeune femme veut s'installer à la
campagne la rencontre commence comme un
entretien d'embauché
alors moi j'ai une petite fille qui a 4
ans et demi oui alors ça ça nous
intéresse parce que moi j'ai une
expérience dans le tourisme dans le
social j'ai un bts tourisme option
montagne à touriste motion pour la
convaincre de choisir breuzon jeanine se
lance dans une opération séduction elle
veut lui montrer la beauté de cette
vallée du cantal
[Musique]
je travaille je suis je j'habite un
logement convenable j'ai ma petite vie
organisée avec ma fille seulement c'est
vrai que je cherche un lieu pour faire
le rêve de ma vie faire vivre un village
du rural c'est vraiment mon souhait
profond et je me vois très bien ici à
les revoir 3 no verdes travis à la fleur
par conquise mais il lui faut encore
trouver du travail pour gagner sa vie à
bruson
deux semaines plus tard le 4 juillet
l'heure des grandes vacances a sonné
toi tu vas me laver la figure c'est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça va être à
la rentrée si je te renvoie à lui aulas
je pense qu'il ya là où c'est à vous
parce que les bonnes vacances
1 qui comprend plusieurs du programme
entre
le maître quittent l'école et le village
reste à savoir si c'est un au revoir ou
un adieu
dernier espoir pour bronze ont gagné
devant le tribunal administratif
ce 17 juillet à clermont-ferrand un
homme les attend il s'agit de lionel
paillardin président de l'association
écho les territoires son rôle défendre
les services publics
il est habitué à attaquer les
inspections académiques devant tous les
tribunaux de france des principaux donne
une fois sur deux sauf peut-être à
clermont ferrand et youtube ont même eu
des difficultés mais pour l'heure c'est
à dire en général ça se passe comment
clermont ferrand prévôt ferrand d'une
gueule dans la salle d'audience
jeanine salue ses adversaires les
représentants de l'inspection académique
l'audience va commencer nous n'avons pas
été autorisés à la filmer au bout d'une
heure et demie le magistrat mais le
jugement en délibéré
le sort de l'école est entre ses mains
deux jours plus tard le maire et jeanine
vont enfin connaître la décision du juge
il s'apprête à téléphoner au greffe du
tribunal qui va leur donner le verdict
on est un petit peu dans le même état
quand on est rentré à l'audience autour
bon après ce sera je crois peut-être
encore pire ba est ce qu'on pense ce
monsieur le maire vous je suis sceptique
oliva de son recul et çà et là de
reculer
allô bonjour ici sinon de creusot le
résultat de l'audience
la décision est suspendue décision
suspendue le maire n'est pas sûr de ce
que cela signifie pas parfait la
décision se savait où on allait nation
d'accord peut pas refaire je vous
remercie
on voit alors jaloux tu peux me faire la
bise nom me fais pas souvent mais là tu
peux le travail quand c est passé bien
on prend le cycle et on fait le tour du
village
super
[Musique]
on a gagné on a gagné
voilà c'est bien
et puis c'est ophélie peux-tu avoir payé
ton cou où il s'est figé et aux enfants
sur un colosse aux enfants un an et demi
plus tard en février 2009
nous sommes retournés à breuzon en ce
matin d'hiver une nouvelle petite fille
prend le chemin de l'école il s'agit
d'ilona l'enfant de fleurs
la jeune femme qui avait répondu à
l'annonce de jeanine
fleurs habite depuis huit mois à brison
un choix sans regret j'ai pris la
meilleure décision de ma vie je crois
j'ai tout j'ai tout lâché pour venir est
vraiment vraiment je regarde pas si
c'était à refaire je n'hésiterais
peut-être encore moins longtemps je me
poserai peut-être une question est quoi
ça vous plaît autant de vivre ici parce
que j'ai une vie peut-être plus plus
sereine plus saine plus plus en accord
avec ce que j'avais
mais cette fragile dynamique pourrait
bien être stoppée net chez elle jeannine
est très inquiète elle vient d'apprendre
une mauvaise nouvelle
voilà la montagne du haut se février
2009 avec en première à la une la carte
scolaire du cantal est ce qui s'est fait
à 8
voilà j'ai appris par le journal que
encore une fois bon un an et demi plus
tard en février 2009
nous sommes retournés un breuzon en ce
matin d'hiver une nouvelle petite fille
prend le chemin de l'école il s'agit
d'ilona l'enfant de fleurs la jeune
femme qui avait répondu l annonce de
jénine peut-être une seule école par
content bon peut-être pour des problèmes
de budget mais si on regarde en réalité
sacré de gros problèmes parce que lé
campagne si elles n'ont plus d'école
elles ne peuvent pas elles ne peuvent
pas espérer voir en renouveau elles ne
peuvent pas espérer voir des gens venir
s'installer à nouveau à la campagne
alors qui a réellement une volonté de
revenir vers le milieu rural de vivre
différemment
il ne s'est pas représenté aux dernières
élections sous son mandat il aura tout
fait pour sauver l'école
après s'être battu pour le faire à
maintenir ouvertes de voir que nous à
ferme comme la fin de la ferme ça fait
pas plaisir depuis 20 ans c'est l'âme de
la commune qui va disparaître ou gens
vous baissez les bras là aujourd'hui
mais moi je vais pas de pouvoir je vais
pas pouvoir jouer j'aurai été toujours à
la commune je vais encore essayer de
devoir de maintenir encore davantage ou
et faire le nécessaire d'accueillir des
familles grâce à son combat
plusieurs nouvelles familles ont voulu
habiter breuzon
[Musique]
mais elles n'ont pas trouvé de logement
à louer pourtant la mairie possède un
vaste appartement vide juste au dessus
de l'école si la nouvelle municipalité
avait accepté de le louer l'école ne
serait peut-être pas menacée aujourd'hui
nous avons contacté le nouveau maire de
bezons mais il a refusé toute interview
[Musique]
le 10 mars dernier l'inspection
académique a donné son verdict c'est la
fermeture une décision que le nouveau
maire de bronze on ne compte pas
attaquer devant les tribunaux cette fois
ci l'école a peu de chance d'être sauvé
un lundi matin ordinaire à l'hôpital de
carhaix
je viens un coup de fil va troubler le
calme de cette matinée un conseil
exécutif vient d'être brusquement
convoqué marie-laure l'infirmière a peur
d'une mauvaise nouvelle tu es d'accord
sur mon bureau je décembre fut retour
des services pour les prévenir de death
en tout cas un conseil exécutif s'est
jamais de bon augure
même si c'est une fausse alerte ça
montre quand même on réagit cela fait de
longues semaines qu'une épée de damoclès
pèse sur les services de chirurgie et de
maternité
[Musique]
l'incertitude ne va pas durer leur
inquiétude est bien fondée la fermeture
se confiant à tout à l'heure
le 6 juin ils ont un sexe à fermerait le
6 juin
en quinze jours le personnel est
abasourdi dans moins de deux semaines
on ne naîtra plus on opérera plus à
carhaix les premiers médecins sortent du
conseil exécutif
[Musique]
c'est réellement la catastrophe annoncée
qu'est-ce qu'on fait leur maison avec
mon avancée que propose déjà une
première réponse dans la rue demain
quelle qu'elle soit mais non la presse
ils vont arriver
c'est dur mais on va se retrouver dans
un telle trouille aura plus rien du tout
il y aura plus de services publics y
aura plus de travail et nous on y croise
des ips on restera vailhès c'est une
honte c'est vraiment une volonté est là
je trouve qu'on devrait enfin bon je
sais pas ce qu'on devrait faire je sais
très très vite
le bureau du directeur de l'hôpital est
envahi c'est lui qui est chargé
d'appliquer la décision de la rh
l'agencé régionale d'hospitalisation
je n'ai pas le choix je n'ai pas le
choix
la décision elle est par ici moi j'ai
effectivement l arrêté mais obligés de
les tenir
allez on n'a jamais entendu parler
d'humanité d'accompagnement de
solidarité des mots qui ne connaissent
pas du tout qu'est ce qu'ils vont
devenir les personnes âgées ici ils ont
80 ans leurs enfants sont loin pourquoi
ils continueront à brest pour se repérer
si on les opère vous pourrez y aurait
quelqu'un pour s'occuper d'eux moi je
pense pas non il n'aura pas mais quatre
planches ça coûte moins cher que des
soins et c'est lamentable dialogue de
sourds entre ceux pour qui la santé pour
tous n'a pas de prix et celui pour qui
elle a un coût
ce que le nom personnel ne comprennent
pas c'est qu'on a changé de logique
budgétaire on est passé de 2004 à
aujourd'hui à une tarification à
l'activité
donc du coup aujourd'hui si nous sommes
un établissement qui ne produit pas
d'activité chirurgicale qui ne produit
pas d'activité au ctri call ou qui
produit pas non plus d'activité médicale
suffisamment dense et bien il mange
grenouille c'est à dire qu'effectivement
il se retourne des recettes qui
s'amenuise ce qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui l'établissement perd à
peu près deux cent dix mille euros par
mois ce ne sont pas les premiers
services hospitaliers que françois-henri
berthou va fermer
avant d'arriver à carhaix il a déjà
restructuré plusieurs petits hôpitaux
aux yeux des défenseurs de l'hôpital
c'est un fossoyeur expérimentés on va en
ville annoncé à toulouse 18 heures et si
on prend la voiture on klaxonne fait des
bouts rustre
[Musique]
l'hôpital m'a fermé
rendez vous ce soir à 18 heures devant
l'hôpital à date et épouse de saguenay
on ferme
nous sommes à lundi les rues sont
désertes
mais le message va passer à 18 heures
trois mille personnes sont rassemblées
devant l'hôpital
une foule hostile que le directeur est
sommée d'affronter
ce matin j'ai reçu un fax l' agence
régionale de l'hospitalisation a décidé
de suspendre l'activité de gynécologie
obstétrique et de chirurgie à compter du
6 juin prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14h12 reddition
tous
mais tous
[Applaudissements]
le directeur regagne son bureau sous les
huées mais des usagers lui emboîte le
pas et le poursuivre de leurs invectives
je l'entends bordel de merde t'es bonne
réponse à gérer collaborateurs de l'état
qui a voulu permet aux de carre
échec on l'assumé mais ça peut vous fait
mal ça veut peut-être que dans quelques
années jusqu'à loin car elle met une
mais n'ont pas pu nous envoyer vous
n'êtes plus un gamin ça mérite qu'on la
voit une grande part de responsabilité
une énorme pavé sont habitées je peux
tout seul non voudrais pas google gmail
vous aurez votre pâte on aura le temps
vous croyez d'envoyer dans à chaque
instant comme ça des grands blessés sur
brest sûr kaymer sauf on aura le temps
vous croyez au public on leur décrit et
vous pouvez vous méritez vous faire huer
quand nous aider
[Applaudissements]
à l'appel du maire la foule se déplace
jusqu'à la gendarmerie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un lieu symbolique que christian troadec
n'a pas choisi par hasard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain à la maternité
les rendez vous programmés sont assurés
mais ces bébés ne naîtront pas à carhaix
le personnel de la maternité applique
les nouvelles consignes photocopier les
dossiers et les rendre aux futures
mamans
je sais pas ce que je vais faire ma base
il disait on va faire des messages comme
à la maison pour quelqu'un que j'aime
bien dit je ne peux pas parce que je
meurs de peur déjà je sais que je savais
que j'avais un coup chez agritel malgré
ça j'avais peur mais encore accoucher à
la maison et si ça se complique le temps
de courir aller jusqu'à 13 qu'elle perd
tous ses repères même temps j'y venais
je vous donnais pas possible
[Applaudissements]
vous allez prendre contact fait l'objet
la faire coucou entre votre choix c'est
le plus tôt possible puisque les délais
le savez peut-être défunt petit peu long
d'accord ouais encourage pas de
continuation a dit au revoir chaque fois
c'est le même quand même émotion qui
ressort à la main soit au coeur quand on
sait que c'est des femmes à qui on dit
pas au revoir au mois prochain
c'est au revoir tout court il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de suites à donner
c'est une vraie émotion je me dis qu'au
fil des jours on va peut-être l'accepter
un peu plus facilement mais pour
l'instant c'est pas le cas du tout à
l'entrée de l'hôpital le camping de la
résistance s'est agrandi le combat si
radicalise désemparés
une usagère et une puéricultrice de la
maternité entament une grève de la faim
[Musique]
de quoi découvrir n'en restait qu'un peu
je trouve que c'est très très dur comme
action j'ai du mal quand même mari m'a
dit qu'elle allait faire la grève de la
faim je joue ça dure parce que je trouve
que c'est quelque part se faire violence
à son organisme et jusqu'à donner un
monde courage parce que j'en serai
totalement incapable moi personnellement
ça me rase pas ce que je pense être
capable de faire je suis pas capable ou
peu capables d'aller dans la rue et de
crier de faire ça et la colère n'avons
plus comme ça en plus elles sont
déterminées c'est ça qui me fait le plus
peur je me doute bien que ce sera pas
quelque chose à la légère on les subit
rapport m'apportait rien à voir tous les
jours étaient comptés à vayrac c'est
trop dur et ben on les gave chacun
résiste à sa manière mais c'est un
combat de tous les instants
ou presque en ces heures difficiles
la famille reste le refuge la force de
marie-laure mettez tout blanc des malins
de quoi non tu as commencé un peut-être
voir le cas
toc amis
moi j'ai besoin de me ressourcer et de
prendre du temps auprès de ma famille
mais c'est pour ça que je me rends
compte que les gens qui sont tout en en
combat c'est quand même très prenant et
pour moi je pense qu'à à long terme
c'est pas compatible avec une vie
familiale à l'eca mis en route parce
qu'il pleut les enfants ouais mais après
tu redescends pour les douars mon loulou
voilà pour faire à manger chinois
on ouvre des sachets en ce moment marie
laure n'a plus le temps de mijoter des
petits plats mais elle veille à ce que
le sort de l'hôpital ne préoccupe pas
ses enfants quand ils me posent des
questions sinon jacques j'ai vite fait
ce que j'ai pas envie 2 2 les barbes et
avec ça tu me pose des questions je
réponde en trouant je veux pas d'emblée
leur en parler je répond à leurs
questions
et puis si je suis trop avec l'hôpital
ils savent où me le faire rappeler un
camille plus qu'une semaine et la
maternité et la chirurgie fermeront à
carhaix mais les carhaisiens vont se
battre jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chez didier valérie dans la ferme coupé
par les travaux de l'autoroute
la situation est grave
privé de la moitié des terres et de
l'exploitation de poulet ils sont en
plus chassés de leurs maisons
expropriées ils doivent quitter les
lieux d'ici la fin de l'année
aliénor la société concessionnaire va
raser la ferme aux quatre générations se
sont succédé et avec elle deux autres
habitations que didier valérie venait de
construire pour y loger leurs parents
respectifs
depuis qu'ils ont appris la nouvelle il
y a deux ans didier valérie vivent dans
la vieille ferme en chantier il avait
commencé des travaux de rénovation ils
ont dû tout un été dans notre projet en
fait on voulait on voulait ici qu'à
s'est cassé le mur pour faire une baie
vitrée
l'idée c'était en fait de deux ça donne
sur d'autres champs derrière enfin qui
est maintenant le tracé de l'autoroute
mais à l'époque c'était notre champ et
donc ça donnait sur les poulets donc on
avait un oeil sur l'élevage en même
temps il ya une belle vue enfin voilà on
a un oeil sur l'élevage sur les bois
c'était sympa colle donc voilà c'est là
c'était la future salle de bains cosy
bien on vient propre avec une douche à
l'italienne enfin voilà et ben voilà
c'est tombé à l'eau
pour l'instant bain en histoire que là
les haricots je monte vite fait mais
vend cette pièce moi elle me fait mal au
ventre parce que j'en ai honte est quand
on reçoit nos toilettes aujourd'hui
c'est ce à quoi
et voilà depuis on est que sur des
choses branchés comme ça la chaudière
elle est branchée là dessus la machine à
laver en eau dans la chambre de ma fille
c'est pareil voilà ça fait deux ans
c'est du provisoire qui devient
définitif c'est vraiment difficile
privé de terre le couple a dû trouver
d'autres sources de revenus
valérie travail pour deux associations d
aide à l'enfance par le sport elle
partage son temps entre pau et paris et
perçoit un petit salaire didier lui
s'est mis à son compte et vendu minérale
pour les animaux tous les jours il fait
des livraisons chez les agriculteurs des
environs
c'est une activité provisoire en
attendant des jours meilleurs
on va dire c'est la valeur des deux mi
temps
on n'y a pas beaucoup de revenus mais
plutôt que de rester sans rien faire je
préfère faire cette activité là je vais
que la commune sont là ouais bon album
est à jeter menée du 12
projeté prévu de 100 kg comme comme
d'habitude dans la région tous les
agriculteurs connaissent la situation de
didier
il est le plus touché le seul à perdre
ses terres et sa maison à cause de
l'autoroute sont repartis 0 0 et au
départ aliénor avait proposé quatre cent
soixante mille euros pour acheter les
trois maisons et les neuf hectares de
terres à ce prix là didier valérie ont
refusé de vendre
ils ont saisi un avocat de pau m garcia
est assignée aliénor devant les
tribunaux
dans un premier temps ils ont obtenu
gain de cause mais le constructeur a
refusé de payer le prix demandé
la décision sera bientôt trancher devant
la cour d'appel
aliénor donc a été condamné en première
instance à pratiquement quatre fois plus
que ce qu'elle avait proposé de payer
comme analytes et à la famille c'est
pour ça que dans la balance un million
huit cent mille euros qu'aliénor refuse
de payer car le cas d aramon pourrait
donner des idées à d'autres
propriétaires
valérie et didier ont réussi à tenir
tête
mais ils sont les seuls la plupart des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui ont signé parce
qu'ils ont eu peur du résultat ils ont
eu peur de s'engager et je le comprends
nous même si on n'avait pas été dans la
disposition de perdre les maisons on
aurait certainement signer aussi on a eu
aussi les deux négociateurs entraîne une
faire une pression énorme à mon mari en
lui disant monsieur armand vous mettez
votre famille en danger si vous acceptez
pas de signer à si vous allez au
tribunal vous aurez encore moins et
c'est vraiment les négociations qui se
sont mal passées ils ont été ils ont ils
ont été des ils ont fait les gangsters
c'est des cowboys
c'est vrai quand on joue sur la peur on
fait peur aux gens on leur dit vous
allez tout perdre si vous allez en
justice mais c'est véritablement un
chantage heureusement de la famille
armes en heure et bien ne pas céder à ce
chantage
pour les aramon le combat continue au
foyer municipal
tous les villageois concernés par
l'autoroute ont été conviés à une
réunion les participants ne sont pas
très nombreux la plupart ont été avertis
le jour même par un coup de fil du maire
jean léon cazenave soutient le projet de
l'a 65
pourtant l'autoroute va couper son
village en deux
qu'est ce que l'on voulait faire drôle
c'est pareil au niveau de la garonne
après
la verrue sera sur le nez tout
toute notre vie et celle de vos enfants
ne savons même
mais à bordeaux
mérité les futurs riverains de l'a 65
ont été conviés en fait à une séance de
cinéma organisé par a'liénor la société
concessionnaire sur la commune de doumit
comme on l'a fait sur les
on fait sur les communes voisines du
cinéma d'anticipation même puisqu'il
s'agit de montrer à quoi ressemblera le
paysage dans sept ans quand l'autoroute
sera parfaitement intégré à la nature
les organisateurs ont bien fait les
choses le film présenté ce soir et en
trois dimensions
mais au milieu de la projection didier
valérie ont une énorme surprise sur
l'image en 3d
ils voient leur ferme encore debout
intacte
le concessionnaire leur avaient toujours
dit qu'elle serait rasée on veut savoir
ce que devient non ce que deviennent nos
maisons ça c'est sûr alors peut-être
monsieur saïd va peut-être nous répondre
peut-être un peu plus de détails
peut-être non non non voulait pas
répondre non d'accord en fin de compte
vous passez plus sur la raison non il
faut des savoirs et vous y passez dessus
lundi passé
silence général en face une fois de plus
valérie se heurte au mur des
constructeurs de l'autoroute
on essaie de se construire en essayant
de trouver une raison à ce qui nous
arrive est bien là
on sait pas mais c'est très
déstabilisant déstabilise il faut ça
toutes ces procédures à mettre en béton
des stomisés morts pourquoi quand on
nous dit maintenant que la mise au vert
reste et qu'on entend de même teneur
alors ça moi je vas tu n'es pas ils
n'avaient qu'à ne redira vont pas nous
faire attendre deux ans et demi leur
faire faire
pour didier valérie le dossier est loin
d'être bouclé dans quelques jours se
tiendra le procès en appel réclamé par
a'liénor qui doit décider de
l'indemnisation de leurs propriétés à
carhaix le compte à rebours est presque
terminée dans une heure la maternité et
la chirurgie vont fermer
rien n'y a fait pourtant depuis dix
jours les carhaisiens ont tout tenté
pour se faire entendre
à paris ils ont investi le parvis des
droits de l'homme emploi comme si
sarkozy m
près de carhaix et dans toute la
bretagne ils ont bloqué des rails des
routes
qu'est ce qui restera pour soigner les
gens d'ici personne n'aura trois à
quatre médecins pour cent mille
habitants
là on s'arrangera et y aura des morts
bien
on y perd à quimper équipé d'une
catapulte gauloise
ils ont fait le siège de la préfecture
le ton s'est durci
les affrontements aussi
[Musique]
que
la maternité et la chirurgie cesse donc
de fonctionner mais pas dans
l'indifférence
une haie d'honneur salue l'arrivée de
christian troadec le maire de carhaix ne
s'avouent pas vaincus et il n'est pas
seul à refuser la fermeture à refuser la
défaite 108 telus du centre ouest
bretagne unie pour la même cause
ils sont acclamés par une véritable
marée humaine
cinq mille personnes jamais foule si
nombreuse ne s'est pressée devant
l'hôpital comme andré enfants qu'il a
bougé dans les prochains jours nous
rejoindre ici sur ce podium parce
qu'elles ont pris décision extrêmement
important elles ont des idées pour
s'opposer à cette politique de karim
rissouli cette logique purement
comptable couché sur france 2 le
collectif des femmes enceintes a aussi
porté plainte pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui de la leur de celle de leur
bébé à cause de l'éloignement des autres
maternités
enfin pour conclure le maire de cars et
explique pourquoi il est le seul élu à
ne pas porter l'écharpé tricolore
s'était chargé va porter aujourd'hui
pour une simple et bonne raison parce
que la devise est liberté égalité et
fraternité
quant à l'égalité en tout cas j'y crois
plus beaucoup parce que l'égalité des
territoires la trans de leur menu et
quant à la fraternité la fraternité
c'est la solidarité et on attendait la
solidarité de la part de l'état entend
rapport à ce pays
alors en attendant qui nous redonne nos
droits eh bien j'avais ma deuxième et
chat était belle aussi
ces décharges consorts à celle des
barricades et la résistance et la sortie
sud ont déjà commencé à reculer
on va gagner
à quelques mètres de la tribune la
fermeture des deux services devient une
réalité
ewan cinq ans vient de se casser le
coude
ironie du sort sa mère est aide
soignante au bloc opératoire ils vont
être transférés à l'hôpital de quimper à
une heure de carhaix les non violence
qui vient nous chercher nous envoie
là-bas que j'ai dormir là bas on arrive
à garder le nôtre puisque l'acte ou
fortement le docteur mais marc
chirurgien orthopédiste et tout aussi
désappointé
on est capable ici est brutalement on
trouve confirmée dans l'ambulance a
envoyé la boxe pour ma part
[Musique]
en plus c'est quelqu'un de chez nous
qu'est-ce-qui
[Applaudissements]
pour rien
ce jour là parce que la chirurgie était
fermé la victime d'un accident de la
route a perdu 3 litre de sang pendant
son transfert de carhaix à saint brieuc
à mont-de-marsan la capitale des landes
les bruits de l'autoroute ne préoccupe
pas la population
l'a65 passera à 10 km d'ici avec un
échangeur prévu pour desservir la ville
la promesse d'un avenir meilleur ce
jour-là l'état organise dans la ville
une réunion de suivi du chantier de
l'a65
les opposants au projet ont été conviés
on retrouve évidemment stéphane yvonne
et françois il faut dire que c'est une
des rares occasions qui leur est donnée
de rencontrer cet homme olivier de
guinaumont et le président d'a'liénor la
société concessionnaire de l'autoroute
parmi les invités un député connu des
pyrénées atlantiques qui rejoint les
élus et les représentants d'associations
tous concernés par le projet enfin
l'homme à la pipe qui arrive d'un pas
pressé c'est le préfet c'est lui qui
anime la réunion
et dès l'ouverture des débats
il met en garde les opposants
je trouve un peu surprenant cette
volonté de s'opposer à un projet qui est
soutenu je le rappelle par tous les élus
légitimes de cette région c'est parti
pour une heure d'explications sur
l'avancée de l'autoroute et sur
l'acquisition des terrains environnants
[Musique]
les impacts résiduels
on fait donc l'objet de mesures
compensatoires pour que vous parlera
tout à l'heure vient la séance des
questions
ce sont les élus qui ouvre le bal jean
louis carrère le numéro deux du conseil
régional d'aquitaine va lui aussi
épinglé les opposants je voudrais dire
aussi que à un moment donné quand il
s'agit d'intérêt général il faut savoir
faire taire et arrêter certaines
procédures qu'ils ont d'autres fermes
que d'irriter le plus grand nombre pour
les élus si les opposants agace le
concessionnaire lui mérite des éloges
moi j'ai rarement vu dans des travaux
aussi importants
ce souci d' écoute et de réponses auprès
des élus locaux d'un concessionnaire
donc je voudrais ici loué la
transparence et l'efficacité
dans l'assemblée les opposants n'en
croient pas leurs oreilles
françois lui laisse éclater sa colère il
doit y avoir les bons élèves
et puis les cancres dont je fais partie
- pour ne pas se louer de du travail que
fait aliénor tout autour de moi moi je
vois des gens qui se font massacrer des
gens qui se font écraser et ça n'est
absolument pas le paysage idyllique
encore une fois qu'on nous fait passer
ici c'est monstrueux ce que vous faites
vous ne prenez aucun cas de tous les
particuliers alors les fayots là bas
qu'ils sont contents du projet vont se
rendre compte dans dix ans ils sont
encore là que c'est une catastrophe
les fayots j'ai bien dit monsieur kb je
dis pas n'importe quoi vous vous
défendez un projet qui est minable
[Applaudissements]
accélère encore le préfet va ensuite
expédié la réunion une heure de débat
montre en main et pas une minute de plus
et donc je vais ou libérer merci à vous
de votre attention
pas assez en tout cas pour que françois
et eu le temps de se calmer
la prise en compte individuelle bonjour
monsieur l expo peut-être nominale
ces projets sont hyper bien présente et
il n'y a rien sur le terrain qui se
passe comme ça vous n'êtes pas au
courant de ce que chez nous n'ont
d'autres acteurs tels autres acteurs
tous les gens tous les jours et quand on
vient vous propose proposer un problème
particulier j'ai touché du meilleur
série madame darrieussecq je vais
trouver tout mais on n'est pas des
opposants pur et dur on essaye de vous
donner depuis des années des années tous
les chiffres qui ce n'est pas ce début
de discussion avec françois bayrou qui a
convaincu françois le député s'éloigne
laissant là les opposants et leurs
questions
l'étang des neuf fontaines le petit coin
de paradis de stéphane est à son tour
menacée
l'autoroute avance les machines à
défricher sont à l'oeuvre une grande
saignée déchire désormais la forêt
aujourd'hui stéphane françois et
quelques opposants tentent une ultime
action pour éviter la destruction de ce
havre de paix les voilà assis sur des
vélos accroché à des arbres un pied de
nez à une récente campagne publicitaire
de la région aquitaine
oui on va rester là toute la journée
domaines montrent d'autres planteurs
volontaires d'en prendre le relais en
bouge pas on ne bougera pas on restera
là en eau machine sera obligé de
s'arrêter
appelé à la rescousse les gendarmes
viennent poliment aux nouvelles non je
vois ce qui se passe bon appétit or les
opposants restent campés sur leurs
positions
bien assis sur leur vélo seul françois
bientôt devant des forces de l'ordre il
a finalement reçu la proposition écrite
du rachat de son petit bout de terrain
elle est assez loin des 189 euros
avancés par les négociateurs et on
propose 19 euros 25 en tout et pour tout
comme indemnisation
c'est monstrueux c'est la proposition
écrite que j'ai d'aliénor on peut
s'arranger à l'amiable
si je suis pas d'accord on va au
tribunal
bon
le face à face entre les machines et les
opposants va durer douze jours
douze jours assis sur des vélos à
repousser l'attaqué et défricheuse et
puis un matin en l'absence de françois
et des autres les machines ont fait leur
oeuvre
le viaduc de l'autoroute a65 passera
bien au-dessus de l'étang des neuf
fontaines
palais de justice de pau pour la famille
aramon le combat judiciaire se poursuit
avec aliénor ce matin valérie et didier
ont rendez-vous à la cour d'appel
[Applaudissements]
peu de précieux l'inca
donc
le concessionnaire après avoir perdu en
première instance a fait appel les
aramon avait obtenu 1 million 800 mille
euros de dédommagement contre les 460
mille euros proposé initialement par
a'liénor l'avocat va une nouvelle fois
plaidé la cause de cette famille
traumatisée par l'autoroute de l'argent
nous ne sommes pas autorisés à filmer
l'audience
en ce que j'ai retenu d'entrer dans ce
cas d'yves la boucle à décharge c'est il
n'entraîne une question de principe et
j'avais un petit envie de dire mais
c'est une question d'humains et donc au
niveau de l'humain c'est pas que du
principe c'est de l'humain et il faut
qu'on juge aussi sur l'humeur c'est pas
possible de continuer à traiter des
dossiers d'expropriation uniquement sur
le principe la justice a finalement
tranché
didier valérie ont reçu un million cent
mille euros s'il avait cédé à la
pression du concessionnaire il aurait eu
moins de la moitié
à ce jour ils sont les seuls à avoir
imposé un tel bras de fer au
constructeur autoroutier pour défendre
leurs droits
en bretagne déjà trois semaines que la
maternité et la chirurgie ont fermé les
carhaisiens n'ont pas lâché prise
pas un jour sans action sans
mobilisation et ils vont finir par
gagner mais c'est la justice qui va leur
donner raison
le tribunal administratif de rennes
saisi par le maire a décidé de suspendre
les arrêtés de fermeture cette joie
immense
[Musique]
ses dimensions parce que ça fait des
semaines de lutte c'est dix septième
semaine de lutte devant l'hôpital de
carhaix la foule se rassemble à nouveau
mais cette fois pour apprécier sa
victoire et fêter le héros du jour
maître hermann avocat qui a fait
entendre à la justice l'exception
géographique de carhaix et le danger
pour tous les habitants de la région
d'être privé de chirurgie et de
maternité
[Applaudissements]
un autre sort a été réservé au directeur
de l'hôpital qui a été muté à saint
laurent du maroni au coeur de la jungle
de guyane on a tout gagné et j'ai du mal
à retenir mes larmes je vais pas rester
très longtemps mais les ruraux
on va gagner jeudi en tout à l'heure en
opère les femmes en droit d'accoucher
[Musique]
ouais
m
tous les bébés nés pendant les 21 jours
de fermeture de la maternité ont été
fait citoyen d'honneur de la ville de
carhaix pour celles qui n'ont pas encore
accouché le soulagement est immense
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qu'on a fait à porter ses fruits
pour merck ont la flemme
moi j'ai deux mois où je crois j'ai pas
profiter de ma grossesse sont pas
profité j'ai fait quand boisset
les choix de mes collègues sont pareils
peu
là les choses pas
nous a volé une partie de notre
grossesse l'accouchement j'accouche dans
un mois et demi deux mois j'ai un peu de
ton com
voilà je coucherais un carré comme on
l'avait dit depuis des milliers
tang et en criant notre conscience
tranquille
jusqu'à nouvel ordre le carhaisien n'est
donc plus une espèce en voie de
disparition
d'ailleurs
à
thélot le troisième fils du maire et de
nadine sa compagne est né à la maternité
de carhaix comme tout carhaisien qui se
respecte il donne déjà de la voix
[Musique]